putting factions in titanfall to help
with the customization aspect of the
game in the way that you can choose
whoever you want it to be commentating
your game and being in the dropship at
the beginning of each match but I think
we can all agree that after hearing a
plenty of times it can get really
annoying so I came up with some ideas
that might be good to help it change it
and make them more enjoyable so the
first thing that would be a good change
is different intro animations like
jumping a different way out of the
dropship
or the commander saying different
dialogue other than their one line that
they use all the time another idea that
I had is having faction specific camos
for each faction I asked a few people on
reddit if they agreed and a lot of
people were complaining that they were
hitting generation 10 for a faction and
that there's nothing worth their time
getting by adding more items gives more
people an incentive to grow up to grind
out that certain faction that they like
some more ideas consisted of people
wanting to have their custom AI back
from titanfall 1 now if none of you did
play titanfall 1 about halfway through
the games like life cycle there was an
update that added three different type
of AI to be talking while your Titan was
talking like instead of having like
Ronan's OS talking while you're playing
is Ronin it would be one of the three
that you hand-picked yourself I thought
this was a great addition to the game
and I'm surprised they didn't have it
back in another thing that they could
have done was adding more dialogue into
the game to listen to you know going
back to the in-game type of dialogue
instead of saying their same lines all
over and over again and this is my
personal favorite thing was having a
different look on your character when
with a different faction and everybody
knows that when you switch or tactical
you change your look but what if you
switched your tactical to cloak and
let's say the Angel City elites cloak
looked a lot different than the six
force cloak I believe this is a good
idea because it helps diversify some of
the pilots and then you can kind of tell
a faction there on not that that that's
a huge problem but you know it gives
more it gives more variety to the game
as I said in the beginning Reese Paul
made a good idea releasing these
factions but they need to be more
diverse than they kind of are having
different camels from factions and
making your character look different now
dependent on your tacticals and factions
could give this game more variety anyway
I hope you did find this video enjoyable
and informative and if you did hit that
like button and comment below other
changes that I didn't list that you
might have thought of while watching
this video if you want to see more
titanfall 2 hit that subscribe button I
try to put out videos every two or three
days but thank you guys have a great
rest of your day and peace out